how can a movie make 400 million dollars
and still be a box office bomb according
to Dwayne Johnson it can't be this is
the Black Adam box office controversy
explained the year was 2007. Dwayne The
Rock Johnson's Hollywood career was only
beginning to gain traction and superhero
Centric movies are far from the shore
fire cinematic money makers that soon
become nevertheless it was announced at
the longtime WWE sensation would
starring a big screen comic book
adaptation focused on Shazam but he
wouldn't portray the tenured print hero
rather had taken the role of his
greatest enemy teth Adam better known as
Black Adam there's no one on this planet
that can stop me around 15 years after
he first signed on for the role Johnson
finally got to play The Man in Black in
2022 so was it the change in the
hierarchy of power in the DC Universe
that Johnson promised well critics
didn't much care for Black Adam but
General audiences seem to have been
happy enough with the movie however
things on looking too great at the box
office the film is hovering around the
400 million dollar Mark worldwide and
according to some controversial reports
that makes the movie a box office bomb
you're probably wondering how could the
film be a bomb with a wide world gross
as impressive as that as some Outlets
are alleging it all comes down to the
movie's budget as laid out by variety
Black Adam costs around 195 million
dollars to produce but the costs don't
stop there you also have to account for
the film's marketing budget which most
agrees sit somewhere between 80 million
dollars and 100 million dollars on the
high end that's in a neighborhood of 300
million dollars but we're still not done
after all it costs money to get a film
like Black Adam in theaters around half
of the cash accumulated due to ticket
sales according to a bombshell report by
variety Black Adam will have to make
around 600 million dollars globally in
order to break even that's taking into
account the film's budget its marketing
push at the movie theaters share of the
prophets according to variety's
financial sources Black Adam is on track
to lose Millions after that report was
made public sources closer to Warner
Brothers indicated to slash film that
variety's initial report is inaccurate
and that the break-even point for Black
Adam is 425 million dollars not 600
million dollars so the movie still
stands a chance of breaking even when
the final numbers roll in that was
corroborated with a report by deadline
whose film Finance sources called the
claims of black Adam's failure simply
not true according to deadline the film
is on track to profit somewhere between
52 million dollars and 72 million
dollars Dwayne Johnson Black Adam
himself also weighed in on the
controversy trumpeting black Adam's
success and comparing the movie's
grosses to the first Captain America
movie which netted 370 million dollars
globally in 2011. one question remains
though what went wrong to make black
Adam's success so debatable Black Adam
was released on October 21 22 22 and
over the course of that weekend it did
pretty well for itself globally it took
in just under 143 million dollars a much
better performance than the opening
weekend of Shazam back in late March
2019. as the weeks went on however the
movie progressively took in less and
less a phenomenon hardly uncommon in the
film World however things went from bad
to worst for Black Adam during the week
of November 11th since it had no choice
but to compete against a juggernaut in
the comic book movie World black panther
wakanda forever
foreign
coogler's latest foray into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Came Out Swinging
during its opening weekend the
long-awaited sea quarter 2018's black
panther made a staggering 330 million
dollars in its opening weekend pushing
Black Adam into the second highest
Earnest spots after weeks at number one
Dwayne Johnson himself even acknowledged
the box office defeat congratulating the
wakanda forever team on Twitter as well
as Instagram and admitting that the
Marvel Studio sequel gave Black Adam a
run for its money at the box office that
wasn't the end of black Adam's woes
though after all it's no secret that
after years on the entertainment scene
the MCU is a slick well-oiled machine
the films and television shows fit
together nicely the actors stick around
and there's a consistent Vision behind
the entire franchise versus when it
comes to characters Heavy Hitters and
Niche favorites alike standard chance to
lead successful projects on the other
hand DC films have faced the Perpetual
identity crisis for years with a slate
full of new entries into the already
already struggling DC extended Universe
Standalone experiments and franchise
starters suffice to say it's a bit of a
jumbled mess thankfully James Gunn and
Peter saffron are now at the helm of DC
studios are Warner Brothers Discovery
subdivision designed to keep DC
Productions on the right track first
it'll take some time for this initiative
to really kick into high gear for years
fans have been jerked around with
recasts retries story inconsistencies
and more which have made it difficult to
go out and enjoy most DC movies it'll
take time to rebuild Goodwill among fans
but even amid the financial controversy
and relatively lukewarm reviews Black
Adam inching into the black at the box
office will be a solid enough first step
foreign